Bộ ít tế vừa bán hành phuyên cao người dân thực hiện các bình phá phòng bệnh sốt viết trong cao điểm của dịch.
Theo Bộ ít tế, hiện nay bắt đầu vào buộc cao điểm của dịch sốt viết, bình có viết cơ bùng phát và dịch viên túc tạm nếu cộp đồng không chú đậu, tích thực hiện các bình phá phòng chón dịch.
Để phòng bệnh cho bản thân, ra đình và cộp đồng, Bộ ít tế phuyên cao người dân chú đậu thực hiện các bình phá phòng bệnh sau.
Để kiến các dụ cụ chứ nước để mối không đại chứng.
Dịch loang quan, bò người bằng cách thả cá và dụ cụ chứ nước lớn thông dựa dụ cụ chứ nước của vả nhỏ.
Thành nước mình hoa bỏ mối dụ hoa chất sịt ở chung vào bát nước kê chân trả.
Bỏ cá vật liệu phê thải các hông nước tự nhiên không cho mối đại chứng như trái, lọc, mạnh trái, vỏ dừa, lốt, bỏ xe cú, hoặc trái.
Mùa màn mà quân ảo dài phòng mối đốt.
Bộ hộp với nạn ít tế khi phương hoa chất phòng, chống dịch.
Hí sốt đến ngày cơ dự tế để khám không tự lụ chị tài nhá.